[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur une planète malade pas dans en bonne
santé
l'humanité dépend de la diversité
animale
et de la diversité végétale qui nous
fournit
de la nourriture
la fertilisation des sols
la pollinisation
ou bien l'ascension de nos excédents de
dioxyde de carbone de même que bien
d'autres services
une planète saine est aussi une
condition sinequanone de la résilience
de nos économies
nos croyances notre rythme de vie
notre bonheur et notre bien-être et
c'est prouvé scientifiquement
dépendent de cette nature
pourtant
la nature se porte mal
et notre proximité physique et
culturelle avec la nature n'a cessé
d'augmenter
140 mètres de perdu en 20 ans par
individu dans le monde
la moitié de la population mondiale vit
en ville bientôt de tiers
nous avons donc cloisonné notre propre
existence avec d'un côté l'homme
et de l'autre la nature ou ce qu'il en
reste
une situation inédite dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
je travaille au chevet de la nature
depuis 24 ans
un métier passion
j'ai d'abord choisi d'élever des animaux
enfants des mammifères des poissons des
reptiles
différentes espèces
et puis j'ai décidé d'observer la nature
de l'étudier
d'en faire ma profession et de la
protéger
125 pinsons des arbres
450 étourneaux
12 pinsons du Nord
10 pipi de farlouse
trois Alouettes des champs
la migration des oiseaux
pendant 3 heures d'observation
le 9 octobre 2010
48 966 oiseaux de 22 espèces
un véritable spectacle de la nature
j'ai aussi la chance
de manipuler des oiseaux de capturer des
oiseaux sauvages parfois de seulement 10
g
j'ai posé des milliers de bagues
sur ces milliers d'oiseaux des oiseaux
qui par d'autres mains habiles ont été
recapurés dans différents pays
l'Angleterre la Belgique la Tchéquie
l'Espagne le Mali ou le Sénégal des
oiseaux de seulement 10 g
le vivant une passion dévorante pour
comprendre le vivant
alors voilà les sciences j'en ai fait
mon métier j'ai fait des animations mais
aussi des conférences en m'associant un
différents chercheurs de différents
domaines
mais voilà j'ai vite compris que la
connaissance n'était pas une fin en soi
et que les arguments scientifiques
ne suffisent plus
pour convaincre de la nécessité de
protéger la nature
alors j'ai décidé de prendre un autre
chemin
un petit chemin de travers
de sensibiliser et d'informer autrement
par les sens plus que par la raison
par une approche
sensorielle voire spirituelle
cela pour un naturaliste comme moi
ou un biologiste cela nécessite de
sortir de l'entre-soi de mêler les
mondes
mais les la culture l'écologie les
sciences l'art
de décloisonner les mondes
pour vous convaincre
je vous faire vivre trois expériences
sensorielles
qui touchent l'émotion vous savez
l'émotion ne ment pas elle nous indique
ce que nous sommes d'où nous venons
la première expérience vous l'avez vécu
tout à l'heure en introduction
une véritable tragédie pour cette
population de foot Bassan unique en
France sur l'île Rousse
mais pire en 2022 la même année 40
colonies ont été touchées par la grippe
aviaire sur les 53 référencés dans le
monde des dizaines de milliers d'oiseaux
sont morts
la perte d'un patrimoine partiellement
alors j'aurais pu vous faire une
conférence avec différentes
collaborations scientifiques des
graphiques vous diffusez les
publications internationales en anglais
mais là l'espace de 3 minutes et je l'ai
testé auprès de différents acteurs du
territoire parfois des gens un peu
réservés sur la question de la pression
de la nature en trois minutes l'oeuvre
associée aussi à la musique nous touche
le cœur
je vous faire vivre une deuxième
expérience simplement auditive et tout à
l'heure vous pourrez même fermer les
yeux pendant cette expérience
en trois décennies nous avons perdu 30%
de nos oiseaux communs les oiseaux que
vous connaissez les rouges-gorges les
hirondelles les moineaux domestiques les
Linottes mélodieuses
scientifiquement parlant c'est grâce à
des points d'écoute
que l'on peut mettre en évidence la
perte et le déclin de ces populations
pour vous rendre compte de ce déclin
il y a une publication qui a permis de
mettre et de produire
deux sons que je vais vous faire écouter
le premier dans le sud de l'Angleterre
en 1998 le second 20 ans plus tard
au même endroit écoutez le premier son
[Musique]
le deuxième son en 2018 au même endroit
alors voici en quelques secondes
comment par nos sens nous pouvons
percevoir le déclin de nos populations
d'oiseaux alors quelqu'un qui n'est
aujourd'hui son référentiel ce sera
cette ambiance sonore
évidemment mais si on subit le même
déclin que les 30 dernières années
on vivra peut-être le printemps
silencieux décrit par
Carson en 1962 aux États-Unis
est-ce que vous êtes prêts
à ne plus vivre cette symphonie
printanière alors que ces oiseaux nous
en chantent dans notre quotidien et un
jour je vous invite ne serait-ce qu'une
fois dans votre vie à vous lever une
demi-heure avant lever du soleil aller
dans le boisement le plus proche de chez
vous
pour écouter cette symphonie printanière
cette musicalité de la nature
troisième expérience
cette fois-ci un visuel
magnifique plein de couleurs qui décrit
un phénomène
incroyable
l'extinction en masse
des insectes volants dans le monde
alors oui
notre manière
de gérer un jardin peut avoir un impact
mais c'est surtout notre manière de
produire à l'échelle de la planète et de
cultiver qui a un impact profond sur ses
insectes rendez-vous compte
plus de 50%
des insectes
en Europe ont disparu entre 20 et 30 ans
c'est inédit et ça peut avoir des
conséquences très très lourdes
voilà une illustration d'un autre déclin
d'un pan de la biodiversité
c'est brutale se déclin de la
biodiversité
je pense que
c'est un manque de bienveillance
manifeste sur le vivant mais un manque
de bienveillance aussi à l'égard de
l'être humain
nous dépendons de cette nature
ici aujourd'hui au delà des mots
scientifiques des études scientifiques
qui sortent par centaines pour décrire
ce déclin de diversité
j'ai voulu vous montrer
l'importance des créations artistiques
au culturelles pour nous toucher et
peut-être nous faire réfléchir
et puis nous reconnecter à la nature
je pense que l'enfant intérieur que nous
avons à chacun de nous on doit le
reconnecter le retrouver le reconnecter
à la nature c'est important
un message aussi pour vous montrer
que ces productions artistiques et
culturelles ne dépendent pas uniquement
dénaturalistes ou des biologistes ou de
l'écologie d'une manière générale
et ces œuvres je pense que dans chacun
de vos territoires elles peuvent nous
unir
on peut mêler
l'art et la science sous forme d'atelier
voire de festivals
par exemple ici je rêve dans mon
territoire de vie familiale de créer un
jour un festival qu'on nommerait sept
arts cette
île
pour rendre hommage
à cette oasis du biodiversité incroyable
la réserve naturelle nationale des
septiles
dont dépendent
tant d'activités socio-économiques
mais ce que je veux faire comprendre
aussi c'est que
cette œuvre de la nature
on peut la protéger
moi je peux la protéger vous
par nos différentes sensibilités
il s'agit en fin de compte
de vous faire comprendre que nous avons
le devoir d'être à la hauteur de
l'héritage reçu
et surtout
de léguer parce que c'est un devoir
cette nature dont nous dépendons à nos
enfants et aux générations futures
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme il se doit promis juré de vous de
moi je vais changer car vous soyez au
moins une fois
sur moi la la la la la la la